i'm gonna send this camera that i shot
this video on to one person that
subscribes to my channel turns that
notifications bell on and lets me know
that they've done so in the comments
below
[Music]
half of a man
[Music]
this opening scene was shot on insta360s
new 1rs twin edition with a 5.7 k 360
lens welcome to the world's most
versatile interchangeable lens action
camera
let's see how this modular system works
with these two different lenses in
completely different scenarios
i'm at the two oceans aquarium in cape
town which has like every sea creature
ever
here i'm gonna swap out the 5.7 k 360
lens for the 4k boost lens which is a 48
megapixel sensor for improved image
quality and is waterproof up to 16 feet
[Music]
okay let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
i was so scared in the beginning like
this
it's so weird how close they get
[Applause]
i'm in the atlantic dunes which is like
a miniature desert right outside the
city of cape town
this is the perfect place to swap out
the 4k boost lens with a 5.7 k 360 lens
and shoot my truck drifting in the sand
you know
[Music]
thing is the stabilization on this
camera works so well because when i'm
driving it goes like that
but i think the shot will be like pretty
steady
[Music]
you can never have enough gravity
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
[Applause]
[ __ ]
oh my god
hopefully it made a good shot
okay
before the sun goes down uh because i
have to change the tyre i might as well
sign this video out i hope you enjoyed
it and it was worth busting my tire for
and let me know what you thought of the
insta360 one rs twin edition that was
really fun shooting on and i've linked a
bunch of information below as well as a
link to go and purchase one i highly
suggest it other than that other than
that
sorry i'm ready i'm really freaked out
that was really scary other than that
don't forget you're awesome bruh and
i'll see you soon now let's [ __ ]
change this thing oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god this is so bad this
is so bad
[Music]
you